hey welcome to fear my name is PA and I
have with me that was your cue to say
something I don't know he's been on my
channel before a long long long long
long penis time ago I mean long time ago
that's the same thing see was actually
one of my first subscriber but you guys
don't care right um fear go up
I don't commando I don't really know
open you can only be two P layers right
no no wow let's do it then abort
abortion anyway oh I only just seen this
so we're playing single-player but like
oh yes it's beginning to turn on
subtitles I agree can I do it in
cutscene no one you know is it free now
we could I don't know
did he just say [ __ ] me
I don't really know the story I played
fear too and a little fair one I know
who the characters are by I don't know
how they relate to each other
besides being twins or whatever twins I
mean brothers whatever that was a game
saying that I know this the baby's gonna
suck on her titty like really really
hard
Oh like yeah this is doesn't get any
better than this you like yeah head now
when we gonna scream no she's just gonna
suck on that teddy
I think that's hot what happens at these
I don't know if I have a pervert in mine
or not see the Holy sucked the safety
begins for you now like are we the same
I bleed the head like this like intro
movie was pretty epic actually yeah cuz
you'll see now it's pretty I need to go
offline I'll seem hope this doesn't like
do anything
hello it says that we're playing metal
drift demo I don't think they know what
we're talking about some propria like
some like yeah but don't know what we're
talking about they don't care because
they know they done it too
yeah exactly
dip some being that guy I want to be
Wolverine you can be their gay Russian
guy
I don't want to be like a Russian guy
well you're guessing I gotta do it how
did you know
oh wait I'm not so you were you were
lying I never laugh okay I want to be
that guy you want to be the gay Russian
guy he can go away in card blind look
inside people think oh I see what you
did there I told you it was that big see
I see blood
towards you do your seabass wait that
doesn't make sense
see how gay you are I'm freakin
Wolverine though we feel I mean we have
to do a sound check after this to make
sure no we just just subtitles when
we're done oh yeah as something that's
[ __ ] something's [ __ ] leave
misshaped hands of princeton game
options did it I did it I sold it myself
oh you're a Wolverine guy yeah I know it
are you talking to me I guess I gotta
change the sensitivity oh holy crap game
option troll what shall requite I mean
oh god no this is so entertaining never
go looking go say what did you do to
them see that how do I open this door
space no cube oh you can run
oh are you impressed oh my god you can
run in this case gouache how do I open
I'm shooting it oh yeah oh you can't
actually run it's pretty cool like you
don't like a zombie I'm gonna get you or
a rapist I don't know the same thing
basically oh dude what the [ __ ]
look I'm over here you Jilla yeah I
kissed can you open the freaking door I
don't know how you hold the lever I mean
something oh haha big elaborate moving
animation
rape mode rape mode oh man a slow-mo ass
sorry Millie
hahahaha i punished his butt and then he
died sweet he's loose see they're
talking about me huh oh I opened the
door by hitting it shoot him
I can't I can't see him oh you have a
weapon you opened I know this and trying
whoa what does PC simple there was a
girl next to you it was yeah I didn't
not see it oh god they're shooting
enough out of slow-mo work if we're two
of us I have a weapon to like put a slug
free as well oh cool I have a weapon to
Utila
why whatever jealous agree but for how
long
where did you go oh there I don't get
space kids II are we their penis oh so
it's not for you all right [ __ ] time Oh
God
[ __ ] got a penis I'm bang bang okay 50
parts yeah I don't know how I mean
there's gotta be a bugger yeah that's no
no since we're playing metal demos
oh man wet slurry everything are we that
bad at least we know what to do
sure prefer I don't they still don't
really know the controls neato oh I love
the animation when you do that and then
we punches but if I remember how here we
go
you can thank me later come on show me
your face I want some truth I swear I'm
my mother I almost set him on my
mother's penis but I think because
that's not a good idea to say anyway I
don't know what oh she doesn't appear to
the second name [ __ ] why can i I can't
what are you doing that guy thing him
oh oh please continue don't really know
they control wait for other player let's
hear you can do stuff while I just
written I'm not doing anything
I figured we just make parts cuz I keep
forgetting goodnight alright this first
one will be a long one that's what she's
know my character style is everything
yeah look dad there are some weapons
there if you want some I'll see I'll
take - and - in - hello I know can you
open the door know what doing when you
do that I don't really get it you can
shoot him while I do it oh [ __ ] I'm cool
I am pretty epic there's a gun what cat
I have a gun
Oh what - come the gay guy I told anyway
sweep well I shouldn't say anything I
don't still um know how to open doors
there we go
No Oh God hey go someone to apparently
yeah hey we're shooting me please
[ __ ] I can throw stuff they can
control up the character now however
weapon
oh god I'm down come on draw me bro
I'm not your bro bro whoa whoa oh whoa
let's not go there
wait so fungi Dyson yes I don't oh well
you should've told me no we need to play
this together
well let's end part 1 here and we can
remember revolt you all right look okay
are you sex and loss apart how many FS
are you recording turkey Turkey turkey
Turkey turkey I bet you ate that guy
painting that yes okay we can end part 1
here wave part scene party hello my name
is sea bass or a K it's bizarre on
YouTube I wanna thanks beautiful letting
me upload this video on his channel and
I would keep posting both my videos on
his channel and on my channel just so
know and if you like wandering over
purely it's like beauty why you know
operate very else his upload is on max
so he can't upload any video so I'm
uploading videos for you with fear tree
for you just so you know and I will keep
you posted
so BA hi